an nyu professor says fewer men going to
college will lead to a mating crisis
with the u.s producing too many broke
and alone
men is uh what this professor says let's
see where he's going with this because
the numbers are pretty staggering when
you look at the graduating class this is
an insider story fewer men than women
are attending college which is leading
to a mating crisis new york
professor scott galloway said women made
up 59.5 of college students at the end
of 2021 school year that's 60 percent an
all-time high uh with a comparison to 40
of men enrolled in college but galloway
warned that beyond the classroom the gap
is causing
an existential threat to society
and that we are treating we are creating
a dangerous cohort we have mating
inequality in the country he said adding
that women with college degrees don't
want to partner with men who don't hold
a college degree wait let me read that
one more time
adding that women with college degrees
don't want to partner with men
women with college degrees i want to
partner with men who don't don't have a
college degree the most dangerous person
in the world is a broken alone male and
we are producing too many of them he
said do you agree with them so the the
issue i have with the college thing
right is talk about a bunch of [ __ ]
this dude first of all the reason why
these women at nyu don't want to have
kids is because the college professors
are telling them that their job is more
important than anything that they're
going to do as a family they have
brainwashed an entire generation into
thinking these women have to have a a
career or a family that they somehow
can't have a career and a family that's
number one number two this idea that
because you don't go to college you're
somehow going to end up broken alone
like truckers aren't making 250 grand a
year like soldiers aren't out there
getting laid like plumbers aren't out
there with mansions dude this is the
biggest the the higher education upper
upper echelon education in america is
maybe the biggest issue in our entire
culture because all they do is funnel
ideology and it's non-stop social
pressure come to college do what we tell
you to do fit in do anything that we say
otherwise your life is women aren't
going to like you no job's going to hire
you and then those are the same people
that turn around and they think
communism is the only way because
capitalism has failed them because some
idiot plumber makes more money than they
do as a phd in in basket weaving it's
all bs this guy just exposed everything
here's my question
okay but scott galloway is in
conversation scott galloway isn't one of
those typical liberal college professors
you know who's got gallows
he's a liberal don't don't get me wrong
he's he's a liberal but he's not he's
got very good points he's makes we we
love scott galloway go ahead yeah no
he's an intelligent guy he's a deep
thinker now he also knows how to get
attention and this clearly served its
purpose because i saw him interviewed on
cnn and they almost treated him like an
ally which i didn't expect to see you
know the thing that caught my eye
adam touched on it a little bit but he
equated what's happening as far as the
the disconnect between the proportion of
men and women getting their degrees to
what happens in the most violent
countries and violent societies and
saying that this is like the worst
characteristic you can have because it
leads to unbelievable violence the other
point that he brought up that was really
interesting is the acceptance rates into
college right it is so hard for people
to get into some of these good colleges
right now when he went to school he
referenced the fact that it was a 70
acceptance rate at ucla now it's 14
so it's not it's not as easy as just
saying hey i want to do this because you
know they're going after exceptionalism
and that's what he said the problem is
right now is the colleges are only
accepting exceptionalism and that that's
going to be a big problem going forward
can you see go ahead before i tell you
you give your point kai can you pull up
uh statistic on men or women
historically
graduating with a four-year degree see
if you can get like a 50
your uh uh
number for us to see go ahead adam yeah
i think everyone's made some some valid
points i think the most important thing
is that we're actually having this
discussion for so long
it was you have to go to college you
have to do this there was a blueprint to
be successful
not so true anymore now you can go to
trade schools and be successful you
talked about plumbers or truckers
technicians and hvacs people can make
100 grand a year making more than a
college degree even for a lot of people
um
it's it's the conversations needed you
talked about scott galloway i believe
he's the guy that we read his article a
few months ago about graduates need to
be warriors not wokesters that's the
same guy kai yes yes okay so he's not
some woke liberal nyu professor or
anything like that let me be the point
that's not what i was saying i'm not
saying that you were saying that i'm
just saying about him he's been very
vocal of uh he he he does like making
what's your point though not now give
like a conversation is needed however
let's let's bring this back who's this
needed for
34 year olds don't need to learn about
this because you're already freaking
graduated
17 and 18 year old young men or even
women need to be paying attention to
this so our younger crowd our younger
audience needs to understand all right
this is a perspective should i go to
college should i not go to college one
of the greatest videos you've ever done
pat was why college is a scam maybe it
is let me tell you if i'm going to
college at ucla and at the 60 40 ratio
chicks sign me up but i'll see you right
that's going to motivate some kids guys
there's two points just to let me
clarify i'm not anti-education i am not
anti-education okay but the the idea
that college is somehow the only way to
get educated is nonsensical man all
right we all know that
do we
education in in america today exists for
two things all right in my mind not to
paint with a broad brush interesting to
make people obedient and that's why
there's less crime it's it's an
obedience school it's a finishing school
okay teaches people how to be good
employees and you know listen to
authority and the other side of it is is
it sells education right half of the
point of education the only job you can
get is to go into education and then
sell it's a giant ponzi scheme but but
to me i'm going pure logic okay let's go
pure logic set aside the emotion look at
the stats guys can you guys flip it for
the screen to show this chart please
okay um
and and jorge do me a favor next time
don't put this in here because my leg
hits it especially when we got four
um so if you look at this it says
percentage of u.s population
who have completed four years of college
or more from 1940 to 2020 okay that's 80
years
if you look at it it was closer matter
of fact we were not even going to
college 80 years ago so only 5.5 of the
population
male
graduated from college and only 3.8 of
women graduated college so if you put
the two together 5.5 plus 3.8 is what
uh 503.8 is a 3.8 so 9.3 what's 5.5
divided by 9.3
do 5.5 divided by 9.3
55 93. so it used to be 60 59 percent
man
uh uh uh uh 41 women and on this poll
blue
as blue is male and black is female yeah
so but go to
the the separation has been so don't let
the separation look like a big number
because it's still the same ratio like
5.5 on 3 8 is the same ratio but it
looks like it's closer
we've been the same so the real change
happened what year the real change
happened in 2008 okay so what happened
to no wait that's all i want to know i
mean if you go to waste and you
is it the housing crisis but what are
the housing crisis oh you know what
presidential change obama came in okay
so obama came and obama was if you
remember when obama came obama said you
know uh
to get more degrees in
uh what was he saying education lawyer
you know go be a teacher go be a nurse
go be there and 08 people
the gap closed and more people started
going to school so so then obama effect
obama encouraged people to get graduates
i mean college but also something to
think about there was no jobs the job
markets suck so people were like what
the hell am i going to do with myself
all i'm telling you is i'm looking at
data right now and then now women flip
and they're taking a lead with men okay
so why let's let's let's process that
from the standpoint of why on one end
uh uh when did it become
when when was the push male female what
year is that 15 14 female took over in
15 14 go back to 15
even 15 14. yeah 14 women were ahead of
men so when did the push become to say
men and women are equal when did that
push out that was in the 60s that was in
the 60s okay so if you go from 60s
so you got the push from there to when
did the push become for women to become
executives entrepreneurs
yeah
what was that third weight feminism is
early 90s mid 90s third wave feminism
would you say third wave feminism is in
early 90s yeah myself i should know this
my sister's gonna be so mad at me okay
but but whatever the stat may be there's
a reason for this so it's greater and
then what this leads to
the more independence i was talking to
this guy marion toopey i think his name
is he wrote this book 10 uh trends to
pay attention to and one of the numbers
was the fact that he said by 20 to uh
2100 america's the world's only got nine
billion people living in or seven
billion people living in it based on how
many kids people are having so
women becoming more career oriented when
it comes down to a decision i was
talking to a very powerful woman in
america one disclosure name we're having
dinner together and i said that why
don't you have any kids she says i
wanted to compete with men and i knew if
i would have had kids i wouldn't be able
to compete with man because i don't want
to give up that 90 days and then having
to raise a kid and not being able to
stay after the office i want to compete
with them and because of that i made it
to the top of my field and i beat a lot
of my male peers okay so now if that
competition happens
and a baby's being born per
that number drops to 1.5 1.4 1.7 this is
when the population starts decreasing
rather than increasing so we have to be
around 2.4
per family for it to increase so 2.4
kids per family 2.4 the population to
start increasing you start increasing at
one point this is why you look at right
now the
uh the age the the oldest country in the
world from the superpowers is china 36.8
is the average age if you want to pull
up china's average age because they did
the one baby because they did the one
baby now they're back to two babies by
the way and you know they're thinking
about going to three babies but you got
the uh 38.4 i think u.s is 38.1
go to us now us's
average age average age u.s is
38.1 and then go to india now look at
india's average age it's like 26. that's
26 exactly what it is 26.4 28.4
japan's is old by the way kai's killing
it today oh he misspelled japan what
what happened so close guys
i'm saying 40. they are the oldest
country if you have two kids and your
wife gets pregnant in china is the
oldest country well they don't
understand that that's actually a good
question i think back in the day
it's not close i mean that was a very
strict rule uh-huh japan's 40 japan is
the oldest country 45-5 italy go to the
youngest
go to the youngest who's at the bottom
niger 15 chad uganda a lot of african
countries afghanistan is 16 and a half
this is why china loves afghanistan with
the whole lithium
zimbab zambia who else is at the top
that's a uh
nigeria 17 8 keep going
uh uh congo kenya
uh sudan guatemala is 194 shout out to
mario and uh rose right that's rosa's
birthday today rose happy birthday to
you rose happy birthday to you rose okay
and then we got ecuador 26 and then
you've got india 22. where's china on
this list
china's 38 ford we looked at that
already okay so they're in the middle of
the list kind of japan go back to the
top guy
japan is the oldest country
and then germany colombia if you have
one seven that number keeps decreasing
huh countries got to average 2.4 or
higher okay so you both of you guys have
kind of screwed the whole thing up
that's why you're stepping up we have 12
kids
did i see that that columbia's average
age is 23 kai well what i've learned
from hanging out with adam is that
columbia definitely has the best banter
out of
any country see poppy yeah you know what
one one thing about this is what about
the acceptance uh you would think the
admissions departments of all these
major universities would be cognizant of
this and trying to
change the the percentage a little bit
admit more guys
i think that's way way after i think
they're like step nine okay then what
about what about the cost and how that's
inhibiting this as well because there is
so much pressure on kids right now to
get into the college they want to it's
internal pressure they're feeling it
from their parents and they are
definitely feeling it from their peers i
mean it controls teenagers lives in some
communities it really does if you're
getting accepted to colleagues into the
right college their perceived mind and
you have one daughter that's graduated
college and uh correct ivana is she's
15. so she's a sophomore kind of a role
right now 10 20. he's 12. he's 12 years
old i just i really i really take a lot
of umbrage with the fact that this guy
somehow equates not going to college
with somehow ending up being broke and
alone like like like going to college is
the only way that you're not going to be
stupid well i would argue with you but i
got to go define umbrage real quick and
i'll be right back so this is the thing
i'm going to change my umbrage if you if
you have if you have an internet
connection you have an education yeah
true if you have a computer but you have
an education what he's referring to is
this disparity and that eventually is
going to cause a problem as opposed to
trying to force everybody to go to
college i think he's looking at the 60
40 and saying there's an issue down the
road
when i my senior college you know what
as i realized i had completely wasted
all the money in time just on on hanging
out and playing baseball and partying
was
i spent four years in college learning
from and about people throughout history
who never went to college what phd does
tesla have
like
benjamin franklin i'm i'm reading i'm
reading the federal freaking point
i'm reading the federalist papers and
i'm enthralled in my political science
classes the percentage of the population
of the college in 1540 listen
the world where
you know you study on your own and
you're curious you're always wanting to
learn and it's a never-ending thing
versus you've got four years to learn
and the rest of your life it's going to
set you up and probably you know all
this stuff a couple quick points about
college just real quick we have confused
as a society
access to information with education
like the ability to be able to google
something memorize it for 24 hours and
regurgitate it on a test it's not
knowing anything agreed let me get a
phone so i can call this australia go
ahead and you have two points you have a
couple good points here that that
college doesn't equal education back in
the day when we were growing up y'all we
had encyclopedias that was our or
one thing that that you know college
isn't just about education it's just not
about being book smart it's about being
social smart yeah a lot of colleges
understanding
who to be friends with how to network
who not to hang out with how to maybe
start a business how to
you know how to interact in the club how
to go approach a girl how many people
these days never even know how to call a
girl or talk to a girl because it's all
online and and dating apps what have you
you've got to spend a couple years
getting just rejected in person
but and college will teach you all these
things that that you won't not hear
about that's what
shaq went on tinder what happened to him
did you guys hear the story about shaq
and sure he got blown up shaq went on
tinder he says i tried tinder he said so
i reached out to this one girl i like
she was pretty and she responded back
and says shaq would never be on tinder
get the hell out of here says i got off
tinder because nobody believed yeah
hey can you play that video from the
guardian on what happened with australia
so so at the end are you going to send
your kids to college and support it yeah
yeah you are you got to be honest yes
when you have kids you're going to be
like i don't know i i think
by the in 20 years from now we'll see
what there were the games at but but for
you like is are you going to be
encouraging it are you going to say do
whatever you want to do uh
i'm i'm trade school military army
entrepreneurship college i'm growing
entrepreneurs pat that's it all right
how about you i don't know if you heard
this but 100 of the world's problems are
going to be solved by entrepreneurs i
actually agree with whoever said that by
the way you know you know what i think
gerard's answer is going to be 100 of
his kids are going to go to uc berkeley
yes yes
yes or no oh man can you imagine that
i'd love to see them when they come back
and see that
hey dad you're clueless you have no clue
what you're talking about you're so
selfish
he's already going to college now that
their private school is 75 grand a year
he's going to do the university
the amount of amount of books these guys
have read yes they don't score came the
other day when we're doing the teacher
you know you know when you're doing your
what do you call this stuff you're
sitting out with the teacher and they
give you parents here's where you here's
the organization here's where the
average student is in america here's
where the average student's in our
school and here's where average student
is here's where your kid is at right so
it was boom boom boom dylan yeah [ __ ]
business he's an interesting tico does
better groups
also good i have thought about this and
this is this is the truth if he if he or
she wants to be a lawyer or a doctor go
to college if you don't know what you
want to do if you're going to be a
communications major kite
engineer an engineer
engineer go coder
backpack through europe for six months
so your roads that way learn how to
party and network doing that it'll cost
you a lot less money then come back man
and be an electrician and be retired by
45 bro but you know what i'm talking
about the communications materials what
the hell is your video internship
without it yeah that one's classic how's
your day going what the hell is that
those gators i just i just think so much
of what we do is wrong like we were
taught if anybody if you had to go into
a trade you were somehow a loser you
know you you failed you gave up on life
now you know if i had to do over it was
army though army was like your dummy
right you're not the you're it
15 years they got three houses they're
killing it man you look at something my
buddy's got a wife he's got kids he's
got he's got a house when when he got
married early at 24 you're like dude
what are you doing you're throwing your
life away now he's like five years away
from retirement his kids are going to be
18 they're going to be out of the house
he's going to he's going to have a
pension he's killing it so if you enjoy
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]